now we've got a a national baseball hall
of famer
and um one of the all-time greats from
minnesota and also here in southern
california is a los angeles and
california angel talking about his new
autobiography which is available now
wherever books are sold
the author of one tough out fighting off
life's curveballs
the great rod carew how are you sir
i am doing good rich thank you so much
for having me
you got it in our commercial break for
our youtube and our uh siriusxm audience
we were showing um
uh you are you're available to be uh
chosen in a home run derby
app 2020 home run derby app that a lot
of people are playing right now in
quarantine
uh you're eating 800 foot home runs in
the old yankee stadium if you're aware
of that rod
and you can stay here yeah i i know that
i've hit a a couple up in the
upper deck but um those are just luck
those dudes
these these ones are shown right now
they go 800 feet
halfway to long island uh do you know
how how many uh
career home runs did you hit do you know
that number off the top of your head oh
yeah
uh 92 chris brockman
correct all right i i by the way i'd
know that number
uh as well who's the toughest pitcher
you had to face rod
that you thought that you know i i need
to come to to work today correct
uh the main guy was rudy may and um
also ron guidry those are guys that
i really had to have my game on that day
louisiana lightning who uh the year
after you won the mvp was a cy young
award winner one of the one of the best
left-handers
uh in the game and then who did you own
which pitcher did you say okay this is
this is going to be my this is going to
be my day today it's my birthday today
rod well i think catfish hunter i think
i did well
real well against them no kidding
why was that just because that just
happened
he just challenged you you know he just
came right at you
he didn't play games when he when he was
on the mound he didn't play games he was
out there to get you out
if it's in three pitches he was going to
get you out
american league batting title winner for
seven times rod crew baseball hall of
famer here on the rich eisen show
um i guess walk me through your
autobiography here rod why
for those who may not know but why do
you call it one tough out fighting off
life's curveballs
rod well rich you know kudos to uh
reggie jackson
he named the book um
because playing against him for so many
years you know he noticed that
i wasn't an easy out so um
i've had some things that has happened
in my life and uh
uh they were tough and uh reggie felt
that way so
kudos to him for uh naming the book you
know one tough out
so um for those who again who who may
not know and
what are some of the stories that you
were telling in your autobiography
rod well you know we uh go back to some
of the twin stuff
against calvin griffith and
the way that i got to the to the
minnesota twins organization
um but those were a far cry from uh
what i went through you know when i had
my heart attack and
recovering from that that heart attack
and then um talking about um some of the
abuse you uh overcame to even reach the
major leagues
what what what is that about rod well
you know when i was a kid rich i was a
very
cyclic head you know i had uh rheumatic
fever and spent almost a year in the
hospital and
you know my dad just didn't uh take any
particular interest in me even as i
i was growing up playing in the
literally per liter league programs in
in panama um he thought that i was
too much of a pet of my mom's you know
uh
because she really looked after me after
i got sick and
really took care of me so he didn't
think i had it in me to be
uh what i wanted to be was a major
league baseball player
and so why did you continue to play
baseball
how did you first get to how did you
discover the sport rod well you know i
loved it you know i played stickball
if we played stickball in in panama
we used to put the names of jackie
robinson
and ted williams and all the great
hitters on our
broomsticks and that's how we started
um it was a fun thing for us to do and
you know i always wanted to um to be a
major league baseball player because
you know i used to listen to the armed
forces radio on the weekends and when
they said they had
40 50 000 people in the stands watching
the games you know
i just didn't believe them we didn't
have tvs to see it
so i said to my mom you know maybe one
day
i'll get the opportunity to play in
front of uh
50 000 people which that dream came
through
rod carew uh baseball hall of famer here
on the rich eisen show and then just
staying i guess in your in your own um
personal life about some of the
challenges later in life that you
after you're playing career um i'll give
you the floor on that and what you'd
like people to know
about that in advance of reading your
book one tough out
rod well you know rich i uh
i had a a really big heart attack i was
doing
an event for the angels uh at the
stadium
uh the night before that i had the heart
attack
and um you know i i think i flatlined
two or three times so you know i kept
asking
god you know i said don't you want me
aren't you ready for me
don't you need a good hater you know
so you know those are those are my
thoughts and he kept saying to me uh
now i'm not ready for you yet you know
i'll let you know when i'm ready
but uh it was a situation that um
you know i went out and i was cleaning
them up by myself
and um you know after i put my club back
in the bag you know my hands were
getting clammy and
i had like an indigestion burn in my
chest and this first time that ever felt
anything like that and so i it's a good
thing i was on the
the first hole because if i was in a
second hole they they wouldn't found me
a lot but
i was able to back my my card up to the
to the front of the um the clubhouse and
walked inside nonchalant and isolated
and called
call the paramedics because i felt
something was going on
with me and uh the next thing you know i
was laying on the floor and i was
i was out and when i opened my eyes
for some reason i saw this paramedic
with the um zappers and he was yelling
you know let's go we're losing them
let's go we're loosening
and then i i went out again and
and they brought me back but during that
course of that
that one second or two seconds of
seeing the paramedic you know he had
a really glow around him
as he's yelling you know let's go let's
go
and it reminded me so much of michelle
my daughter
when she was in the hospital and i used
to lay in bed with her and read the
magazines
and she'd always tell me you know dad
you can't see him but
my guardian angel is sitting over in the
corner he's got this
big white light around him and he's got
his hands in a prayer
mode and i used to say honey i think
you're
you're having too many drugs you know
but she says oh no no
daddy's here and then when it happened
to me
it was like wow now i believe what she
was saying to me
and and talking about one tough out too
rod the the story of of your
heart as well um that there
is uh the heart that you have inside um
is no is not your own it's an of an nfl
player and this is a story that
we saw on nfl network quite a bit conrad
rueland uh
who is a sixth grader in southern
california
um and about the organ donor uh
and who it is what a story this is sir
well you know i i was out of this i went
to visit my son
school and he was out front running
around and then
he looked at me and he says you're a rod
crew aren't you i said
yes sir says who are you says oh my name
is conrad
he says one day i'm going to grow up to
be an athlete i said to him well
make sure that you study your books
first says oh no i'm a good student
i'm going to be okay you know and that
was the first meeting with him
and here you know how many years later
he turned around to be the young man
that would give me his heart and
and for now prolong my life
i mean that stuff you can't make up ron
i mean and obviously he
he was an nfl an nfl player who
um who died well before his time but the
fact that you met him as a sixth grader
first and
you counseled him on on how to be a a
good person and
and also uh succeed in life it really is
remarkable and you're still
you're friends with his family correct
ron yes we are you know um
after i got out of the hospital um
i was able to my wife and i were able to
visit his family and
uh give his mother the the opportunity
to hear his heartbeat and
you know just put her head on my chest
and and listen to his heartbeat and she
said just like
you know uh the last time that i put my
head on his chest
and heard his heart beat the same
heartbeat so um
you know we became tied to them and
started doing a lot of things with them
uh because conrad's going to be with me
forever so
why not just beautiful rod you're a
beautiful human man and i'm
hoping and i'm assuming uh you're
staying in place i mean talk about
somebody who's at risk um or potentially
vulnerable to this awful virus i would
imagine it's
somebody who's uh had a heart transplant
at age 74.
so um i assume you're you're staying in
place
right ron yes yes sir i am rich you know
and
uh you know i don't
see other people and it's hard for me
because i like talking to people
but i know the risk that i have as far
as having a
heart attack in my immune system uh i
i could just pick it up and and uh
and die so i have self quarantined
myself
in in my home and um it's boring but you
know
it's something that i have to do uh to
stay alive
you bet rod look uh again i i
i know we've met on on occasion and
you've been on the show before if you
just want to
call in and talk and just you know and
and hang out
uh on on this show just just you know
talk baseball
you know and hopefully we have a playing
season to talk about but even if not
just
i'd love to go down one by one every
single all-star you're an 18-time
all-star
i mean all the stories um please i'd
love to
love to help you pass the time at the
very least ron okay
yeah it sounds like a great idea because
you know i love talking about the game i
love talking about the players and
uh you know the state of the game today
and what's going to happen are we going
to play are we not going to play
uh you know those are the things that i
think about all the time
and um the the main thing though is that
um
the guys don't get hurt by it you know
uh
that they don't rush back into playing
re real
soon because you know you never know
what can happen you know uh
and their lives are just as important
and
important as uh everyone else's so
uh it's a tough thing though what we're
what we're faced with today and
god's going to get us through this rich
right back at you rod
it was great to spend time with you and
uh and look for our call we're gonna i'm
gonna reach out maybe just in a couple
of weeks time we'll just
have you back on and i i'd love to know
what you think of today's game and who's
the best hitter and then go down memory
lane i'd love to do it rod let's do that
sounds great sounds great and and thanks
for
so much for giving me a platform to
talk about uh the heart problems because
you know it's a number one disease
killer
in this country and um if i can save
one life you know then uh by me telling
my story and
people listening and making sure that
they're taking care of their hearts
and uh doing the right things uh then
i'm doing my job you are doing that rod
thanks for the call you be taking care
take care of yourself and we'll chat
right uh right around the corner okay
rich thank you
that's the great rod crew hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here